i want to talk a little bit about this
what is a woman question
because it continues to be such a major
issue for the american right wing and
over the weekend at cpac which we will
cover later on in the show
the things that got the most applause
were the most overtly
homophobic and transphobic things they
were ridiculing pronouns they were
ridiculing so-called men and women
sports and on and on and on
and i want to talk about it because it's
like the big thing that republicans now
point to as their sort of gotcha what is
a woman you won't even define it and i
got a great email from a doctor of
sociolinguistics whose name is daniel i
don't want to say more i want to protect
his identity i won't even say what
country he teaches in but daniel sent me
a ton of the information and the
research that i'm incorporating into the
story so the situation is as follows the
right loves to say you liberals can't or
won't answer the simplest question what
is a woman so you can't be trusted with
anything you're not honest you're
pathetic it's such a simple question
what is a woman just answer it and if
you won't or if you can't then it shows
how bad faith and dishonest and radical
you all on the left are so let's start
with is it actually a simple question is
the question what is a woman simple to
answer the reality is that it's not and
now separately there are people saying
is the question even being asked in good
faith by the right and of course it's
not they're asking it to make a
political point they're asking it to
justify their pre-existing political
beliefs but let's put that aside is it a
simple question
defining common nouns is not actually a
simple thing
humans are terrible at defining common
nouns i'll give you an example define
apple without looking it up
all right well i mean without looking it
up i guess i'd say you know it's a round
fruit whose flesh we eat and sometimes
there's red yellow or green or orangish
sort of skin
and often it's crunchy but sometimes
it's more mealy and many of them are
sweet but some of them are tart does
that really help us identify an apple
not really there's all sorts of
exceptions there's many other fruits
which fit that definition
so then i can say well an apple is
malice domestica that's the latin name
so when i say apple what i mean is
mollusc domestica that's just circular
that's not a usable definition i'm not
really telling you anything you can use
to determine whether something you see
is or isn't an apple
now in addition
no definition that i give you
actually encompasses all the contexts
where the word apple is used the big
apple meaning new york city taking a
bite out of the apple as a sales and
marketing term getting some market share
so the reality is that it's not unique
that with the term woman we define it
differently in different contexts the
purpose of the definition is important
what are we trying to do and i'm going
to get to that in a second and in fact
as humans and people who speak english
we can often agree on what is an apple
without a definition
with the looking at the context so the
definition itself is actually not that
important so then as daniel wrote to me
the same applies when we're trying to
define a woman what are we trying to do
by defining woman or thinking about what
a woman is and it depends on the purpose
and the context consider this
if the purpose of defining woman is that
you are a man
looking to reproduce
and you're looking for a woman with whom
you can reproduce well in that
particular
case with that purpose
a trans woman with no uterus is not a
good candidate for your purposes of
defining a woman right in that context
you're talking about an individual
with the female reproductive organs so
that you can make a baby
on the other hand if you're a man
attracted to feminine individuals by
western standards then for you it might
be quite plausible that any woman
meaning a trans woman or not who has the
female form that you're attracted to is
completely and perfectly suited to the
definition of woman that's a different
purpose it's a different context and
this is where we end up with the bad
faith republican questions about what is
a woman they want common nouns defined
so that they can either discriminate
legally or so that it serves whatever
political purpose they want
now there's a big difference between an
apple and a woman with apples apples
can't make claims about whether they are
apples there's no sociocultural element
to apples when it comes to a noun like
woman we actually do have to pay
attention to
who claims to be a woman who is referred
to as a woman who is seen as a woman by
society in order to build up a working
understanding of what it is to be a
woman in society and culture this is all
completely normal republicans don't care
about it they don't care about
linguistics they care only about scoring
political points and putting other
people down so when they say it's so
simple you idiot left this just what is
a woman just give us the definition well
what is the purpose of the definition
what is the context in which you were
seeking it what are you trying to then
determine
with the definition this is normal stuff
in sociolinguistics and in many other
fields
they want to pretend
like it's not and it's as simple as just
what is an apple which by the way is not
actually so simple let me know your
thoughts you can find me on twitter at
deepakman